Superman's in the building what's up  guys it's me cherry tree fort and big  dunk contest is right around the corner  so we're hitting the streets in New York  to have fans recreate these three iconic  dunks here's the catch though they're  gonna have to do it on this toy hoops I  got three dunks for you to choose from  okay I got those before you think  probably was even born yet  okay you got to put the cave right let's  go let's go what's the head and  everything  Oh put his whole arm in the rim  [Laughter]  [Music]  Superman's in the building let's go to  the judges Superman baby  oh yeah that's a talk that's a toss  oh god hey take care you so first he  stuck his arm in the rim just see with  the moves everybody brought out crazy I  wasn't expecting it New York City you  got it now it's time for me to get out  of here  [Music]